this is a production of Cornell
University
this is the Scott Henry training system
and we've probably talked about this in
class it's what we call a dynamic
training system which means we have to
do an adjustment during the growing
season so we've got four clones one two
three four and what we do is we position
the lower tier downwards so when we
looked at the GG oh we've got four
clones but everything grows up and the
Scott Henry system the top grows up and
you can actually see this is what I'm
machine harvested or mechanically
harvested block looks like so you can
see what's left here in terms of where
the fruit was so we had a fruiting zone
up at the top here then we have a bit of
a space and then we have a lower
fruiting zone here and these shoots are
actually positioned downwards so that we
come along just after berry set and flip
this wire downwards so they're growing
up then we flip it down and pull these
shoots down as a result the growth along
the bottom isn't always very good but it
gives us this space here in the training
system that allows for more light and
more airflow so this is something
growers don't always like it's extra
work but the studies that have been done
usually show that this can improve you
well either improving composition so
it's a really good system that many
growers need to consider using so I'm
going to prune this Scott Henry system
and get us down to four cones two that
go out here and two that grow out here
so I was just looking at this to figure
out what I was going to lose and
remember I don't want to lose bull wood
so bull wood is something that's built
in diameter it has long spaces or long
intra nodes between the buds and so I
looked at at this shoot right here and I
thought oh that's bull wood I'm not
going to use that so I thought okay
where am I going to cut this out and I
went to look and then I realized hold on
it's not from this vine
that's as if it is let's pull this out
because they're crazy long okay so this
is how long it is and it's not even from
this vine and it's not from the
neighboring vine it actually comes from
two lines over so this is an absolutely
crazy amount of bull wood I mean this is
gotta be this is what you do not want to
sue so I'm getting rid of that okay so
I'm gonna cut away some of the extra
stuff so that we can figure out exactly
what we're gonna use here so we'll start
with the lower tier first and remember
we want to keep everything close to the
head so that we don't get a spoon where
we're not going to have fruit production
so I've kind of challenged here that's
kind of grill at the bottom so I think
that's probably not gonna be very good
so that's really not a good option for
me these ones here are too far out so
we'll cut those right out of there and
that leaves this one here it's a little
bit gross so I'm gonna see what else we
have for the bottom tier that's too low
not useful that would be a possibility
but it's a little bit big with long
internode so I'm not gonna use that
either so to simplify here we're going
to cut this edge
so looking at what we have here I'm
actually soon a possibility for a clone
that could go along this wire so if I
stretch this one out I've got all of
these buds along here that are gonna
produce shoots whereas if I use this one
I'm gonna I'm gonna have this space here
that doesn't have an issue so I think
I'll use this time to go in this
direction and then along this side this
one doesn't look too bad I'd like it to
be a little more Brown that's a little
gray through there but it might be my
best bet for low note in that direction
so I'm gonna use these two clones so
I'll get rid of this and that's gonna be
my first along here so I'll wrap it for
now we come back with these clone ties
that we use and actually tie those into
place a little bit later in the spring
so for here I think I'm gonna use this
cane it's a little grate or two ends but
we're running into this vine anyways so
then what I can do is get rid of this
whole thing through here because I'm not
gonna use anything that comes from it so
and I think I'll cut it right down it
actually it looks like it's a root
sucker anyway because here is our graft
union here's the Bulge and it's actually
not coming from the graft union so this
is a mistake someone should never have
tied this one up anyway because it could
be the root stock material rather than
then fruit and fruiting wood or cyan
wood so we've got a plane that goes this
way
and a plane that ties out in this
direction this comes from the
neighboring vine so there's our two
cones for our lower tier upper tier it
looks like we've got a little bit more
choice here are probably a possibility
this one might lay out there as well
there we go so that's cleared out of the
way and along here I know I'm not gonna
use anything past this one so I'll get
that out of the way as well and it's
tied in there pretty good with a tune
tie then I'm gonna pull off
there's a lot of vigor in this flock
which is why we have some overlap from
neighboring vines there because we
needed more space to lay out more buds
cut this out so this allows me to look
at what's really good here uh this is
nice nice brown wood but it's just too
big and diameter definitely some bull
wood there that's for useless so we'll
cut that right over there I just damaged
that clean a little bit as I pulled the
other piece out so it's probably still
gonna be okay so that's a good option
still that is probably an even better
option it's a little bit smaller in
diameter and I don't have to worry about
that little piece of bark I just pulled
off so I'm gonna tip that one from the
neighboring vine as is this okay so this
one
and I just hit myself in the face or
hurt on this one we're gonna turn it
this way and then we've got this one
here it's got what we call a persistent
lateral on it so we're gonna get rid of
that persistent lateral we can leave an
extra bud there if we want to make sure
we've got something in the space
although it's pretty long anyway so I'll
probably cut right about there and that
is how I would clean prune this Henry
system so we'll come back with some
clean ties tie those down I've got my
four clones I'll leave that as a renewal
sperm and the vines done ready to go
once we tie it down for this
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu